من الرباط في المغرب ايوبه الحمري مؤسسه
جمعيه نسويات وناشطه في مجال حقوق مجتمع
الميم عين اهلا بك ايوبه واعتذر منك لان
اللغه العربيه لا تزال لا تساعدنا في
التوجه اليك كما ترغبين فانت تعرفين عن
نفسك باي في اللغه الانجليزيه اي هم او هن
ايوبه اولا لام مسيرات فخر في لمجتمع
الميمعان في المغرب كما في سائر الدول
العربيه هل يزعجك هذا الامر وماذا تعني لك
مسيرات الفخر اهلا شكرا بزاف على
الاستضافه
كنظن مساله احنا حاليا في المغرب وفي
المنطقه صعب بزاف على الفخر فكان من
الاسخاص بزاف اللي انا منهم واشخاص
الفخر هو فقط تواجد ديال الاشخاص
المجتمعممين زائد في بلدان اللي هي كتجرب
العلاقات الجنسيه الرضائيه بين الاشخاص
نفس الجنس
بالنسبه لي مسيره الفخر ابتدت
كاحتجاج ماشي احتفال في الاول احتجاج من
اجل ضد العنف البوليسي اللي كانوا كيتعرض
العنف اللي كتعرضوا للاشخاص المجتمعين
زائد في امريكا
منذ البدايه لحد الان كنظن للاسف كانوا
كثير ديال الشركات اللي كيستغلوا الوقيته
ديال يعني الشهر شهر الفخر باش انهم
يديروا التسويق ديال المنتجات ديالهم هو
الشيء اللي بعد كثير على الهدف ديال ديال
الفخر واللي هو يكون ان الاشخاص يخرجوا
للشارع من اسلحه احتجاج ضد العنف ضد
الاضطهاد والكراه